[Música]
salud en directo américa de france a 24
más romero sala con nosotros ya en el
estudio mar yo por supuesto seguimos
hablando de reino unido esta vez para
hablar por supuesto de la particular
estrategia del gobierno de boris johnson
frente a la pandemia de ccoo y 19 - días
raúl así hoy no soltamos ese tema y
además porque particularmente esta
estrategia de boris johnson fue muy
comentada al inicio de la pandemia no sé
si recordamos esos inicios marzo de 2020
en la que el mundo se apresuraba a
cerrar mientras que todavía boris
johnson era reticente a ser es vamos a
recordar una declaración de ese primer
ministro
vamos a tomar las medidas adecuadas en
el momento adecuado sin seguir
dictámenes políticos sino siguiendo el
mejor consejo científico y médico del
mundo
hay buenos motivos para enfrentar una
epidemia estrictamente desde una
perspectiva científica y esto es lo que
hemos hecho sigo creyendo que es la
forma adecuada de hacerlo para este país
sin embargo raúl esas medidas adecuadas
en el momento adecuado pues la verdad no
todo el mundo comparte que eso fuera así
de hecho se publicó en octubre de 2021
un informe de varias comisiones del
parlamento británico el que señalaban
varios de los errores de boris johnson
iniciando por que decían que había unos
supuestos generales ya muy fatalistas en
el que estoy asumido desde el principio
que se iba a intentar conseguir esa
inmunidad de rebaño a costa de perder
muchas vidas eso tuvo consecuencias como
por ejemplo retrasar varias políticas
una de ellas pues las cuarentenas
totales pero también las pruebas
generales los testeos masivos por kobe
19 criticaron que el sistema de rastreo
tampoco funcionó que se sobrecargaron
muchos otros servicios sociales por
ejemplo los asilos no para no intentar
para no llevar a toda esta gente a los
hospitales
una falta de transparencia general a la
hora de tomar decisiones entonces esto
es un resumen de ese informe que se
pueden consultar online ahora vamos a
hablar más de las decisiones más
controvertidas del gobierno del saliente
boris johnson si al menos respecto a la
pandemia porque sabemos que las bajas de
esas decisiones han sido controvertidas
pero vamos a repasar la cronología de su
gobierno frente a la pandemia empezando
por el principio el 13 de marzo que fue
el día que se hicieron esas
declaraciones tan confusas sobre la
inmunidad de rebaño se contradijeron
pues el consejo científico con el
ministro de salud entonces pues no
quedaba claro cuál era la estrategia que
quería implementar el gobierno de boris
johnson y pues esa misma fecha fueron la
primera vez que se instauraron medidas
como estas restricciones masivas de
eventos grandes pero todavía no se
implementaron las cuarentenas otro gran
punto también fue cuando el principal
consejero de pues científico del río
unido dijo que estas 20 mil muertes iban
a ser un resultado positivo o un buen
resultado de la pandemia de condiciones
y conseguían no traspasar
es ese umbral de fallecimientos y fue el
23 de marzo que reinó unido- instauró la
cuarentena general varios días incluso
una semana después que muchos de sus
países vecinos el 31 de marzo se desató
el primer a la primera gran confusión de
políticas de boris johnson con el tema
de los tests se compraron 3 millones de
tests que luego resultó que no
funcionaban se pusieron unas promesas de
cifras de títeres diarios que no se
cumplieron de hecho para esa fecha el 31
de marzo si se estaban haciendo se
habían hecho poco más de 8000 pruebas en
todo el reino unido desde el inicio de
la pandemia cuando ya estaban muriendo
unas 800 personas cada día y para
concluir esta primera etapa 13 de abril
se superaron esas 20.000 muertes sólo un
mes después de las primeras afirmaciones
de esas controvertidas afirmaciones
pasamos rápidamente después al tema de
las vacunas que eso sí ha sido una de
las cosas que le han dicho muy positivas
a boris johnson el 30 de abril se
anunció el acuerdo entre astrazéneca y
oxford para y después de investigar una
vacuna al que el gobierno le dio casi en
más de 39 perdón casi 39 millones de
libras
y se convirtió en el primer inversor de
esta investigación de la vacuna 10 de
mayo recordamos otro gran lío si volverá
al trabajo presencial o no boris johnson
aseguró que era seguro volver al trabajo
presencial con unas 500 muertes diarias
de personas por covite 19 un esfuerzo
por volver a la normalidad después de la
pandemia del crono virus que se demostró
que era acelerado también en el 4 de
julio que se hizo un súper sábado para
intentar pues conseguir que la gente
comprara más mover movilizar de nuevo la
economía pero que luego tuvieron que de
nuevo dar marcha atrás igual sucedió con
lo de los tapabocas por ejemplo en
lugares cerrados entonces como vemos
muchos ir hacia adelante ir hacia atrás
con medidas de salud pública que nunca
quedaron muy claras y en todo esto pues
ir y venir pues volvieron a una segunda
cuarentena así es y ese fue quizás uno
de los grandes puntos más
controversiales de estas estrategias del
gobierno de boris johnson quien pues no
recayó sólo sobre él sino sobre un
gabinete también un poco convulsionado
pero bueno básicamente johnson en
retraso hasta el último minuto esa
decisión de instaurar una última
cuarentena eso sucedió el 1 de noviembre
de 2020 que empezó el segundo
aislamiento general y en ese mes de
hecho fue el primer mes que se
anunciaron resultados positivos de la
vacuna damos el salto hasta el 8 de
diciembre que en paz empezó la campaña
de vacunación masiva en reino unido- de
nuevo recordamos que fue una de las más
rápidas en todo el mundo también
impulsadas pues por esa vacuna propia
del reino unido- sin embargo pues este
éxito quedó enturbiado por quizás la
mayor confusión si exceptuamos el tema
de las cuarentenas y de que se saltaran
las cuarentenas que fue el tema de la
navidad no sé si recuerdan navidad 2020
2021 grandes protestas gran enfado entre
la población del reino unido- porque
también se dio marcha adelante o marcha
atrás en cómo iba a ser la cuarentena o
el plan de aislamiento en un momento
pues tan importante como son las
celebraciones festivas de navidad
finalmente terminamos el 7 de enero de
2021 que fue el día que reinó unido-
superó las 100.000 muertes hablando de
muertes
hagamos un repaso actualmente cuántos
muertos porque 19 tiene este país si
hagamos un breve balance actualmente
reino unido- cuenta según las cifras
oficiales al menos porque sabemos que
puede haber un exceso de muertes
180.000 personas que han perdido la vida
a raíz del virus del cob y 19 es uno de
los países con la cifra más alta pero no
es uno de los países con la población
más grande y ahí es donde está ese
contraste no cuando miramos la cifra de
muertes respecto a la población estamos
hablando de que se cuentan dos mil 652
muertes por cada millón de habitantes
una cifra proporcionalmente muy alta de
las más altas de europa superadas sólo
por ejemplo por italia que tuvo esa gran
oleada y que fue el primer país en
recibir el impacto de la pandemia y
además también una tasa muy alta en
reino unido entre los casos que se
detectaron y las personas que con kobe
positivas fallecieron estamos hablando
que llega a ser del 15% esa tasa ha
bajado mucho actualmente está por debajo
del 1% pero en los primeros meses de
pandemia llegó a ser del 15% el 15 por
ciento de personas diagnosticadas con
kobe terminaban falleciendo es una cifra
de nuevo altísimo y muchos creen
científicos también oposición que si se
hubieran implementado cuarentenas antes
y todas estas políticas antes pues
quizás hubiera sido algo más baja
cuarentena y respetadas por el propio
boris johnson y por su núcleo más
cercano de gobierno en el parc y gate
como hemos venido a la actual la mañana
-alejandro más importante que lo llevó a
la renuncia pues donde empezó todo
normal así es raúl e ir y de hecho es
importante recordar que éstas
cuarentenas que están imponiendo ahora
para evitar contagios de kobe
ciertamente no pero es que el mismo
boris johnson a inicios de abril de 2020
se contagia de kobe 19 y tuvo que pasar
unos buenos días hospitalizados incluso
en cuidados intensivos de escuchemos lo
que decía cuando logró superar esa
enfermedad
hoy he dejado el hospital después de una
semana en la que el servicio de salud ha
salvado mi vida sin lugar a dudas
watch express
es difícil encontrar palabras para
expresar mi deuda pero antes de eso
quiero agradecer a todo el mundo en
reino unido por el esfuerzo y sacrificio
que hacen y siguen haciendo
un esfuerzo y sacrificio que estaban
habladores johnson pero que bueno porque
él mismo no hizo exactamente pero
queremos aprovechar también ya que
estaba agradeciendo al end age es que es
como se llama el servicio de salud
público de reino unido es uno de los
servicios públicos con una fama de mejor
funcionamiento de mejor calidad de todo
el mundo sin embargo que ha sucedido
pues de hecho es una de las principales
también críticas de la oposición e
incluso algunos gremios de trabajadores
médicos que después de años de gobiernos
conservadores en reino unido donde
además las prioridades políticas como
hemos venido repasando también han sido
otras este servicio público de salud ha
quedado pues sin el financiamiento que
necesitaba y que cuando estalló la
pandemia del cobat 19 estaba indefenso
de hecho de los grandes escándalos
también cuando el gobierno le dijo no
particularmente orgulloso pero gobierno
les dijo a los trabajadores que tenían
que ir a trabajar con delantales porque
no había suficientes pues servicios y
elementos de protección personales para
hacer frente a esta crisis no también
muchas protestas en términos de los
salarios de las condiciones laborales de
los trabajadores de la salud entonces
pues también terminar recordando que lo
mismo m se ha recomendado que en una
inversión en los servicios de salud
pública es básico para luchar contra
estas emergencias y que años de
gobiernos conservadores entre el 1
hicieron lo contrario algo que le
terminó estallando en las manos también
a boris johnson y reino unido- no fue
centro de estos huecos en los sistemas
de salud que se le vio a todo el mundo
con esta pandemia de kobe 19 esperemos
aprender de estos errores y fortalecer
pues la salud porque sin salud no hay
nada y también para el próximo gobierno
de reino unido que aprenda de los
errores de brillantes esperemos que se
sea a marc como siempre muchísimas
gracias por toda la información de salud
pasamos a nuevamente con rosa pérez
masdéu a seguir repasando la prensa
respecto a este tema